abbiamo mese passato con oggi devo dire
che la quarantena me non dà fastidio
evidenzia la mente da noi manca troppo
dal parco parte che se la cava il tar
potrà uscire per all'aria aperta
sì mi manca allenarmi a pallavolo manca
sicuramente avere la possibilità magari
di andare al ristorante a teatro al
cinema ma sono tutte sofferenze con le
quali riesco a convivere avere momento
quello che più mi pesa in una maniera
assurda che sta iniziando a diventare
difficile l'impossibilità di vedere le
persone anche all'interno delle case
loro soprattutto persone che sono in
quarantena all'inizio e che quindi a un
mese che fanno attenzione secondo tutte
quelle che sono le norme e le migrazioni
ci sono stati dati come sta chiamando
enrico pronto a harry dimmi qual è il
problema
per me dice persone che so che stanno
seguendo tutte quelle che sono state le
indicazioni che ci sono state date e che
quindi fondamentalmente un anno subito
contagio è un po difficile c'è continua
a seguire ovviamente tutte le
indicazioni per un po difficile
mi mancano alcune persone tanto c'è
questo qua da solo non mi pesa stare da
solo e tu mi pesa non poter alternare
questa solitudine con della compagnia il
contrario sarebbe peggio la compagnia
non poterla alterna nella solitudine
io oramai affrontò la questione andare a
fare la spesa con la stessa 1 shall ansa
disinvoltura e la stessa preparazione
che se andassi tipo alla miglior
passerella the runway piace questa cosa
perché l'unico evento mondano al quale
io partecipi da un mese a questa parte
come immagini notti a meno dott
stavo pensando che l'industria tutti gli
i meravigliosi abiti nei primaverili
scusate statua da random perfetta per
niente magistro che non vorrei tanto e
farli insomma già non esco ma intensiva
ad attaccare solo merle mi sembrerebbe
molto edificante comunque sto andando a
fare la spesa per il mio triste e
solitario pranzo di pasqua sono
dopo un mese di 40 io le mie personalità
sfruttiamo se non cede qualcosa e uno
spacco
ciao ragazzi siamo sempre qui con le
iene nel prossimo servizio vi
spiegheremo qual è la giusta angolazione
per darsi le gioie in fronte sono
promozionato da fare la spesa da bene
come outfit insicurezze k fila al
supermercato così sono andato un altro
facciamo troppa finita così sono tornato
a casa anche oggi con flex a secco come
diventando tom hanks in cast away
capelli lunghi barba scorci sia capace
una doccia perché come vi ho detto
faccio pagare mi dona sistema dalla
barba mi rimetto al nuovo insomma come
qua a testimonianza e me la sono fatta
per davvero
[Musica]
[Applauso]
rasoio per levarmi proprio alcuni
pentiti pò qua sotto ma mi pesa
quindi mi lascerò così me ne cascata
indotto non me ne devo dar 10 avanti
l'ho vinto ritornato un essere umano
capelli mi tengo così fino alla fine
goering purtroppo però condividere con
voi il mio outfit dopo la doccia e
sempre questo metto questo questo qui i
miei sandaletti che poi giro per casa e
mi sento un po protetto di punto in un
eterno ho appena finito di fare fisico
da cori e per aiutare l'allenamento mi
sto facendo lancetta con la pasta e
ripasserò che mi sono fatto un paio di
giorni fa ha fatto uno spaghetto al sugo
che ciao ciao assurdo ma sono a pezzi
ragazzi allenamento che stava facendo
anche bene mi sta uccidendo perché ogni
giorno un'ora senza pietà senza niente
niente sono stanco cioè non so se lo
sentite sono felice ma stanco confuso e
felice a confusa e felice
bevete anche poi coca cola io mi senta
brand fuori per aiuto nonna ma che ti
stai vedendo stanno facendo ha visto
quello poi alla fine lui muore
ho già visto ciao ragazzi poi la pasqua
ap ami ami e via
cerchiamo di stare un pochino leggeri
avrà mi sto facendo una rotolata che più
o meno grande quanto il caddy né col
jordan times hanno messo sul terrazzo
con un telo sto tirando le cuoia solo
con i cattivi o chiamate aiuti con gli
occhi del mio spazio vengono ritrovate
qui allora ne sia chiara re l'altro
giorno su instagram mi è venuta in mente
un'idea forse una cazzata
forse è geniale non lo so io ho una
terrazza condominiale che stavo pensando
di scrivere un messaggio a tutti quanti
i condomini proprio per evitare che ci
siano assembramenti perché per carità
del cerro insomma la distanza prima di
tutto quanto vorrei improvvisare una
mini braciolata qui in solitaria ora
secondo me i problemi che si pongono
sono molteplici il primo va beh è la
risoluzione delle controversie con i
vicini non essendo mio uso esclusivo
questa terrazza però insomma su quello
ci si può organizzare il vecchio non ho
mai montato un barbecue da sola la terza
delle questioni che io non ho mai fatto
un abbraccio nata da sola quindi non so
nemmeno che faccia abbia tendenzialmente
in a carbonella tanto anche fare perché
sotto anche così nero forse vuole la
braciolata è troppo voglia prevedere è
evidente in una fattiva ritrovo ore fa
bisogna pregare una cosa questa è la mia
ricetta dipinta cioè come la faccio io
non la fa nessuno dei miei cachet calcio
da chi è l'una di notte e mi sono resa
conto che la uil palomba o ten ha
provveduto mentre vedo una roba spagna
buonasera ragazzi l'una e mezza passata
di notte per niente giù con un would so
se ci vede piccolo e nero e sto andando
a fare una rapina
scherza voltare sempre la mascherina
quando si va fuori anche all'una e mezza
di notte quantità ma io e faccio è stata
assegnata con guido che anche lui deve
fare i bisogni non fosse per questa
piccola creatura non riuscirai mai di
casa io non so se vedete comunque ma ho
disegnato una bocca
nell'eventualità di avere un dialogo con
qualcuno almeno sa che ho una bocca
dietro questa maschera perché non tutte
le maschere portano la b
cosa sconveniente e chi porta gli
occhiali non so se si nota è che quando
si respira quindi se parlano gli
occhiali quindi maskin equivale a non
vedere un camp nou no ti prego di farmi
da bambino bruttissimo smistare e
lasciami stare ragazzi buona pasqua a
tutti pasqua il grillino scusa buona
pasquetta a tutti meno eccezionale
mammamia già oggi hai fatto una pizza
clamoroso ma guardate che roba è la roma
che stanno alla pizzeria taglio
telecamera lurida in questo periodo sto
pieno se po di cose da fare io passo da
aperitivi online a giocare online
a leggere il sole già d'un botto tra
parentesi se volete fatelo sapere perché
alcuni me lo chiedono un book shop tour
generi una un tour della mia libreria
ora non so se sei una cosa mi sembra un
pochino tipo o atti mybag fatemelo
sapere magari lo infilo nel prossimo
week
vi faccio vedere come ordinato i miei
meravigliosi libri sono un po malato
deve ben soleggiato e creato il l'albero
della rancia mattoni le 800 pagine ma
devo essere sincero quando si tratta di
scusate ho pianto ma ho pianto ma non
perché sono triste ho pianto perché è
venuta una bella idea e ogni volta che
ho delle idee belle mi commuovo non so
perché è l'unico modo in cui piango e
coi film triste se non piango mai è una
cosa che ci arriva quando scrivo mi
rimane delle belle che amo dicevo perché
comunque anche quando si parla di libri
dimensioni contano mi dispiace devo
essere onesto fino alla fine a me lo
sento e quando sono onesto ho sempre
bisogno
un po'di tonico mi sento già meglio
inoltre un'altra cosa carmine che è un
mio amico vi si occupa di all'aics che è
un ente benefico super super super super
serio super super affidabile
mi ha chiesto di promuovere la campagna
che stanno facendo proprio per quella
che è l'emergenza kobe calcolate che si
parla di 30 anni di garanzia trasparenza
pura cioè io veramente mettere le palle
sul tavolo per loro vi lascio qui sotto
con kingson chimica ti lascio qui sotto
un link qualora voleste dare una mano a
coronare qualsiasi cifra per venir
incontro alle terapie intensive che in
questo momento stanno messe abbastanza
male ci sono un sacco di realtà che
stanno dando aiuti in questa una cosa
bellissima loro sono una realtà super
super valida nella quale io mi fido e
penso che si debba qualora si può fare
di più grazie a scusate ma volevo dirlo
perché lo diro pure su instagram non ma
ci teneva anche a parlarne qui su
youtube
chi sini e il prossimo episodio
scusate ragazzi ma non sento il dovere
di dovermi dare la mia testimonianza ma
puliamo